qui est la chose qui t'intéresse le
moins mais qui pour toi aime tout le
monde alors je dis pas que c'est pas
bien mais c'est juste que moi ça m'a
jamais parlé mais c'est les mangas je
dirais je pense que j'ai vraiment une
communauté énorme de otaku voilà je
connais les terres pour vous dire à quel
point je suis pas du tout contre ça mais
moi ça m'a jamais trop trop fait kiffer
j'aimais bien des baisers ou quoi mais
quand je vois qu'il y a des gars qui
regardent vraiment des milliers
d'épisodes de manga
je capte pas spécialement mais
tout mon respect pour les gens qui
disent ça tout comme Game of Thrones
finalement voilà
je vais me faire énormément d'ennemis